for astrophotographer Ajit everester any
opportunity to see a space spectacle is
a good enough excuse to use his rooftop
Observatory but this month has given him
more than he wished for enough to get
the whole family out in fact and his
neighborhood
and with it all the necessary equipment
to catch this month's double lunar
Delight
not just one but two full moons both of
them super moons this is again Super
Moon so it is super blue one that's why
it's very special Saturn is up close
with the moon so we can see Saturn also
near to the moon so that's again a very
rare phenomenon
from Gaza to Greece Pakistan to India
Japan and Dubai moon enthusiasts
gathered to see the celestial event
that's also expected to make tidal
flooding worse as its intense
gravitational pull also makes Tides
higher
every month the full moon has a
different name many of these date back
to Native American Roots different
cultures across the world gave them
these names depending on what was
happening in a particular month now the
modern day calendar doesn't follow the
lunar calendar exactly but the moon
names shine on we've got the worm Moon
the wolf Moon the sturgeon moon like the
one we saw at the beginning of this
month the blue moon and the super moon
like this one
the moon's orbit is elliptical following
an oval course around the earth meaning
that at different times it's closer and
further away
the term supermoon was coined in the
late 70s to refer to the point when the
full moon is at its closest point to the
Earth
this super moon is the year's closest
just 357
000 or so kilometers away more than 160
kilometers closer than the one at the
start of the month
according to NASA the apparent size
increase is around 14 percent and since
it's the second full moon it's also
known as a blue moon the term used when
we see it twice in a single month
last time it was in January 2018 but
our first Super Moon of the year was in
July and the fourth and last will be
next month but it'll be more than a
decade until the next super blue moon
for many that seems light years away
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera